et tout d'un coup j'ai su que je l'ai su une fois j'ai
su qu'il avait besoin de
moi jusqu'au jour de ma mort je ne saurai pas pourquoi
je savais qu'il avait besoin de
moi ça pourrait être une
maison fantastique ou peut-être que c'est
parce qu'il a besoin de moi il a besoin de moi il a besoin de
moi il  a besoin de moi il a besoin de moi il a besoin de
moi
c'est comme un jeu de dix cents je vais tenter ma
chance je le ferai parce qu'il a besoin de
moi personne ne l'a jamais demandé auparavant
parce qu'ils n'ont jamais eu besoin de moi
peut-être que c'est parce qu'il est si
long peut-être que c'est parce qu'il n'a jamais eu de
maison  il a besoin de moi il a besoin de moi il a
besoin de moi il a besoin de moi il a besoin de moi il a besoin de moi
une fois pour une fois dans la vie J'ai finalement
découvert que quelqu'un avait besoin de moi et si cela
s'avère
réel alors l'amour peut faire tourner la roue
parce qu'il a besoin de moi, il a besoin de moi  il a besoin de
moi il a besoin de moi il a besoin de moi il a besoin de
moi oh oui il a besoin de moi il a besoin de moi il a
besoin de moi il a besoin de moi il a besoin de moi il a
besoin de
moi et tu vois